ついたついたついたついた今俺の目ってその山から奪ってやって目に入ってされもから
入っ
学校はを作るこれが肇社長ですはいというわけでられると道路タイトルにもある通りな
んですけども
末に来ました真面目シャツを
東京に
引越します
[音楽]
まあまあケアリーです訳ありなんですけどちょっと詳しいか説明していきますね皇居
引越してどうするかとかね色んなあれだね畑をどうするとかな音引っ越すのとかまあ
色々あるんですけどちょっと中央ってちゃんと説明していきます
ねえとりあえず動画のタイプになる時ですね今月2に私は省察を活動の拠点っていう
言い方も正しいかわかんないんですけどもまぁ
を訳して言うと引っ越します
東京に第二から静岡に来ています27ないでしょ
18生の頃が来てるから約9年が2と静岡で活動してきたんですけどやっぱこう
ありがたい事にお仕事がたくさん増えて言っていただいて
東京に行くことが本当に多くなってきたなっていう話を見さん4年間ぐらいずっとぺ
チェックサービス着て言ってるんだからたまに言ってたじゃないですかこのまま静
他にでいいものなのか東京に行くべきなのか何か聞いてみたりしたんですけども
いろんな人と話したり自分の中で考えたりした
結論現状ちょっとあまりに東京が某すぎてとっても嬉しいことがでずっと嬉しいことな
んですけども
東京に行くことが多すぎてもう酒造家拠点はちょっと私チビ c のではないかなと
いう判断
下して東京でちょっと方に移動することになりました
待てああもうちょっと説明させてくださいただなんでそもそ
すぐ引っ越さなかったっていうのを思い出してもらえたらわかると思うんですけども
静岡いいですよ住みやすい労働を取りやすい暴れやすい
苦情を行い大家さん最高もういろんな要素が完璧的でやっぱり東京に引っ越すんで
踏み出せなかったですねずっとで3年くらいだけどもう静岡に帰ってくれて
なさすぎて帰ってきてもなんか刃先の方とにでちゃってあのぶっちゃけ言いましょうは
最近メイン本当に集中できてなくて
やる気がないとかじゃないんですよやりきれないとかじゃなくてもう仕事が多くて投票
行ったりとか帰ってきても大畑系があったりとか考えることが多かったけど薩長っぽい
ことは先にしてるんですねいつは無価値の発音なんでで中ジンジュのことでもやっぱり
こういろんなことをや
入ってるとメインのことを考える力とか少なくて統計で払ってって2かかれない指導が
帰ってこれます帰ってくるやっぱこうだった心だ
ふぅってなっちゃうんですよ
静岡が良すぎるせいか知らないんですけど本来だったら当分仕事もあって言って帰って
来ての指導型 the main はい与え入っ
入ってやるべきなんですけど
ちょっとねええそこまで大変か来なかったですねってがもうと品薄や星だった俺が20
345と語ってひょっとしたら消えて取りこう言ってたかもしれないけどちょっとで
いう体力的にもそもそもその移動して東京の静岡でもがんばれがんばるって言うのが
結構厳しいんくなってきたのかな
時々自分じゃないんですけど
体力的にもちょっとものなんでしょう
静岡静岡帰ってくるとこうズレちゃうんですよね
うーん
音だったらその東京仕事あります2家から静岡帰りますこの帰る時間とかその体力を
深くくらいだったらも東京で動画を撮った方がいいんじゃないかということで東京で
動画を撮れる環境をパスを声出してもいい環境しっかりと止めさせて東京で8動画を
撮れる様にしていこうっていう話でございますなんで引越雪引越しなんですよ活動の
拠点が撮ったり
あとより東京でもメインの動画取れるようにして年間焦って静岡に行くことを減らすっ
ていうかなんですけど結局僕が特にするいかなかった理由の一つとして取りにいくそ
うっていうのあるんですよねぱさんという人多いじゃないですか苦情とか来たりなんか
猫の絵だったらなんか後花火してもワンちゃん大丈夫みたいとかんですけど遠く絶対
無理なんで体や強さにもちょっと実は残っててまだ完全に登記
道で僕は生きていきますとはちょっと山に行ってきません多分静岡でしか撮れない動画
はあると思うしそういう時のためにも一応静岡に大つは持っておきます帰ってきていつ
でも撮れる条件残しておくという感じでございますで引越社祭ではないんですけども
変わることとしては東京でメインチャンネル取りやすくなるよっていうことをこういう
あの付に座って
いいみたいな奴っていう感じですね
んですよ線
静岡に行ってほしいという池すごい多かったんですけどもう
動いよあんまり忙しいアピールしたくないんですけど味噌は c です線賞金土日って
一番 youtube 見られそうな上でも動画1本も出せなくてやることによって
本当に
忙しいアピ少し開けただけでも取れないんだよな
というわけで東京にも引っ越せします
だからなんか例えば1週間東京の主文とがないとかだったら普通に静岡帰ってきます
もちろん卒業の日の見ていきますしね
ただ深淵とに帰ってくるんですよもう疲れちゃってコッチず金田すごいなんかそのなん
か地元メディアの間で酒造が帰ってくるとそりゃもうなーぐったでしょうよ
っていうオチ付きの場になりかけつつある
それがのダメなんですユーチューバーてきてすごい大御所館でてるんですけども全然
まだやりたいことたくさんあるんでもうちょいちょっと最前線で頑張りたいと思って
おります
東京にも動画だしたと思うんですけどもお部屋がありましてただお部屋はあるものの
本当になる壁とだもちょっと暑いから追加もわからなくてた僕付きませんで和気町くる
しもう本当に寝泊りとか編集できるだけのスペースしかない部屋なんで東京
てください書事件とか仕事と仕事ないまーすばもったいないんだって思うんでそこを
有効活用したりそこでメインとが取れたらすごいいいなということで
ねはいもうずーっと言ってたね東京に行くべき方がずっと言ってたんですけども
もうちょっとやばいねありがたいことなんでしっかりこなしたいんですよ
ストレスなくなって引っ越しで見ないとかわかんないんですけども東京に拠点を移して
できることが増えるかもしれませんしてちょっとわからないんですけどもやっぱり仁川
で挑戦やの喧嘩していくことに意味があると思うんでちょっとこんな感じで頑張って
いこうと思います
スケジュール表を見る10月仏削るようなんです青いのが全部予定ですね仕事とかなん
ですけどこの隙間を縫ってメインチャンネルの動画撮ったり畑に出てるんですよもうね
ハチャメチャ
ハチャメチャで相撲という感じでちょっとね静岡に行ってほしい
ルってくださいなきゃいけないんですけど鎧たいよこれを痛いけど
いていいけど動画の方数
ヘルシーたぶんすごい移動時間を長くなら c これらの影響で最近車移動してですね
結構時間内のギャッ新幹線ですけど極力人との接触を避けてくる毎年てるねほんとに
良い道で体力使ってて時間がもったいないし疲れちゃうして体力も時ずれてきてこれで
ね逆に落ち着いて投票で道が取れたら一番これはいいかなと思っています
これがまず8投票に引越
を制するで言うと条件付きって3完全に引っ越しするわけではなく
恐ろしぞな余裕があれば帰っていきます出会えた後畑ですね畑をどうするかっていう
感じなんですけど
もうね畑も東京に引っ越そうかなと思っててまだ全然確定ではないですねじゃあみんな
と話し合ってはいるんですけどなかなか
いい物件がない東京付近で何かの熱波人数多いんでバーチャ刺したのであバーでたいっ
てわけじゃないんですけどもうちょっと年回阿部られそうなクズを行うな仏教今
ちょっと探してる最中なんでまだわからないですよそりゃ仕事がピタッと止まって普通
に静雄が帰ってこれじゃあねっというパターンもあるしこの先の動き次第では分から
ないんですけど一応畑も東京に移動する18視野に入れております
ただ実際は分かりませんそうなると良い本の静岡とわかるかもしれないですけれども
1なく現場は畑は静岡にいます西郷のコンディション最高の応援最高の物件の美談と
動画を撮って欲しいと思ってるんですけども僕の全壊しては減るのは仕方ないかなと
思ってるんですけども
もう畑も作って2年です僕がいない動画の活動も増えたしやっぱりいつまでもハズレ
雑というか前に背負ってやらせる馬券にも僕正直いかないとは思っています
あるデータ成長したと思っている畑のみんなももちろん静岡帰ってきただけはさ木の
動画に出ますけど
叩きを東京のレンズによって動画とかも取ると思うんですけどまぁ今まで以上に
ちょっと畑と僕との動きがまた別々になるのかもしれません
そのまだなんともわからん俺は2年間かけてカメラを育て
切ったわけじゃないんですけども
動画を作る力をつけたと思ってるんで親離れいってわけじゃないんですけど弾みシャツ
お花るって言うから随分経つを使うでもできるっていうのをちょっと見てみたい
なと思ってる
どうなるかわからんけどねほんとに分叩きはそういう感じですそうなるとチャンネル面
に肇社長の畑の風ねシャツをいらなくねって話になってくれるんした畑になってしまい
ますはいという感じでちょっとあの
みんなで話し合ってこういう感じになっておりますあの+なことだと思ってます
忙しいことはとても良いことでただ俺が一番が
貼りたいのははじめ冊を2でもなくツイッターでもなくインスタでもなくテレビの仕事
でもなく畑でもなく肇社長の面チャンネルは絶対俺は何があってもこれだけあっても
話せないと思ってるそこがおろそかになると本当に本末転倒だと思っています
こちら他のこともがんばりますけど俺は何より励み社長のメインチャンネルズーム寝る
で動画を左右
西してやらせていただきますということでちょっとまたメインチャンネルも道が増え
たらいいな
ちょっと新しい生活になじむまでどれくらいかかるか分からないんですけども足に生活
が11月から始まるということでちょっと使えずになる引っ越し道が出ると思うんで
新居
楽しみにしててくださいちょっといろいろされたんでまとめます
3つにまとめ先ず一つ東京に引っ越しますけど朱雀合わせたわけではないということを
重ね社長の畑
静岡に止まりますただ東京にゆっかも
ぶーぶー&ちょっとあの結構楽しみですウードゥー
[音楽]
eleanor